let's let's segue into this next this
next story
from newsweek fact check did missouri
shop say
no guns and ammo for biden supporters
guess what
fact check true it actually happened
they say
president joe biden preached that the
country requires unity to overcome its
challenges in
his inaugural address last week as it
remains divided with the capital riots
early this month blah blah blah
in missouri depending on the
presidential candidate you one voted for
some local residents might not be able
to obtain guns or ammunition at one
store
austin peterson tweeted my local gun
shop announced last night
they do not have any guns or ammunition
available for biden supporters
the comment section of howling leftists
is delicious like hot apple pie with ice
cream
let's keep it going is it the claim the
tweet from him is the claim
a user from the social media forum gab
posted a screenshot of an article
from the gateway pundit an online
political news blog that says we report
the truth and leave the russia collusion
fairy tale to the conspiracy media
with the headline missouri gun shop
announces they don't have guns or ammos
for biden supporters
they have the actual post from facebook
here it's true trigger firearms and
reloading llc
based in jefferson city missouri
recently posted to its facebook business
page
we don't have guns or ammo for biden
supporters sorry for the inconvenience
the company that lists itself as a gun
store on the platform has received more
than 3 000 interactions
and more than 1 000 shares on the post
with mixed reactions from users in the
comment thread
reached by phone trigger firearms and
reloading llc hung up on newsweek's
request for comment
about the facebook post declining to
respond gee you think
facebook user terry plotner wrote
private company so they can do what they
want
but in a comment responding to the gun
shops post an apparent support the
ruling true
they did say this they will not sell
guns or ammo so what does that mean like
you walk in and they're like who'd you
vote for
and you're like that i voted for joe
biden get out yeah who's going to admit
that a gun shop
i don't think they're going to admit it
i don't think they're going to be asking
but this is great pr to bring attention
to their gun store
i know a gun store in new hampshire that
literally had joe biden as the salesman
of the month
a few weeks ago and that brought in a
whole bunch of attention and a lot of
people angry and a lot of people pissed
off and he's like i love it give me all
the attention
uh the guy was also a fan of we are
change which is awkward walking in there
and it's like oh of course yeah that's
amazing
where's where where are the people going
to banks asking for
multi-million dollar investment to start
primer companies or powder companies
because the shortage of all this ammo
yeah like now is the opportunity to get
in the ground floor in fact can you 3d
print ammo
oh we're getting there so we've got a
couple of people working on it
um developments are coming we've got
we've got projectiles we've got casings
uh we're working on we've got half the
chemistry we're working with 3d printed
projectile
not no so we're 3d printing molds that
will let you cast projectiles in any
caliber and diameter you want because in
many places in the world you can't buy
the molds
well so but it's incredible let me let
me ask you
would you provide all of your schematics
to biden's voters sure
yeah i don't care yeah
they're going on the internet for free
yeah anyone can download them
yep go nuts everyone will have them if
they want them i guess that's the point
you know if it's it's freedom
it's you as an individual have the
ability of the technology you can do it
you know i was thinking about what like
you know why these liberals like these
biden supporters are so concerned and
will well first of all let me say
they're willing to support
they're willing to support a man who
says he's gonna outright ban all gun
sales and accessory sales online
did he want to ban ammo too online sales
of ammo yeah i do recall
yeah he wrote a lot of vague generalized
language about not allowing people to
buy a firearm
within a certain amount of period close
to another purchase of a firearm he
talked about banning online sales i
don't have anything gun related
how could you vote for him and then
actually go and expect to buy a gun yeah
and that's a weird question out right
like is how many people are actually
going to this gun shop and saying
they're biden supporters who want to buy
guns
i guess they exist but it's like all
right i'll tell you what you give
no you have to give it to me like it's
being confiscated you know and it's
interesting that this is
oh you got a stink bug in there yeah
yeah it's interesting that this is
happening in in missouri because in
missouri this is also where the
mcclowsky case happened
i'm still trying to look up the latest
information about what's happening with
them but they're the couple that walked
out with firearms with
very poor trigger discipline and very
point very poor
aim discipline uh when a blm uh you know
pretty much protest broke down the fence
of their door and
uh you know they say threatened them so
i'm still trying to find out exactly
what's going on what should they have
done like had their guns pointed down at
the ground well when you see
i think it was patricia miklowski yeah
she literally had
her finger on the trigger and she was
moving the gun around
in a place where it was rightly behind
her husband's head
you're not supposed to do that that's
not smart that's not smart
i feel like everything else was
appropriate given the information that i
have like it was
it was a violent crowd and you're you're
they're they're confronting you on your
property
so i feel like that's okay to point a
gun at them with your finger on the
trigger and be like i'm actually going
to shoot you if you keep coming out
they're on his property in a castle
doctrine state
right so it's like in in some states you
can shoot some before before they even
get on your property
if in order to prevent someone entering
your property some states allow you to
shoot someone's hardcore
yeah and so there's like i don't know
the full details but some states like
new jersey i think new jersey is duty to
retreat meaning
you're in your home in the middle of the
night and you're allowed to own a gun
and then someone breaks in if you can
flee your home you must
but it's really funny because i was
talking to even a cop about this
and he laughed and he was like where are
you gonna go it's your house
where do you go it makes no sense and i
was like yeah and then in other states
they have
castle doctrine with no dude no duty to
retreat but
a duty to enter your home so like let's
say you live in
you know maryland and you're on your
front lawn or something
and you see someone coming towards you
you have to go into your house first
then if they try breaking in you can
defend your home
in places i think like west virginia i'm
pretty sure west virginia's like you see
them on your property you can shoot them
yeah in new york city
you defend yourself you you hurt the
perp you go to jail for the crime of
hurting the perp
so i know many instances in cases where
people had violence brought upon them
they defended themselves and because
they left a mark on the
attacker the aggressor they went to jail
really yeah what you're supposed to do
there's even individuals there's even
stories in the united states where
people were violently attacked
fought back and uh you know
with with extreme cases of even you know
people trying to kill another person
that person defended themselves and they
went to jail so there's there's a number
of cases it all depends on the
jurisdictions and it all depends on who
the attorney general is
and this is why we've seen individuals
like george soros literally bankroll
authority attorney generals all
throughout the country that of course
will play favorable
into the agenda and to the narratives
that they want to push the moral of the
story is simple don't live in blue
states or blue cities yes
yeah you have to go somewhere where
you're allowed to be reasonable
defenders when you do go
leave all of those policies there yes
that's amazing you see you see this
story earlier about a guy from cal he
from california moved to texas
and then was like really upset and angry
like he called it it was not a
conservative utopia
and it was like mono culture just didn't
like it so he leaves and it's like
you know what man that's a good story
you know why he left
yeah he didn't like it he left it's it's
remarkable because
you know we have so many people now
fleeing these big cities and going to
these these red areas where i can
understand why this store is basically
saying
no biden supporters can buy guns because
you've got democrats from
big cities moving to red areas bringing
those policies with them
and then they want to buy guns and then
get them banned later what's the point
like crate crate grandfathered in guns
that only you can sell like like full
auto
you know what do they cost like 20 grand
for for a
like a belt fed full auto machine gun uh
yeah belt fed you're gonna get way up in
there but
because it's grandfathered in the only
way to own it is if it's an existing
right
there's a finite number a lot of people
want them so maybe that's the plan maybe
it's a bunch of rich people being like
if we get guns banned then only we have
the guns and they'll be worth a million
bucks
there you go it's a racket yeah the guy
who moved uh
to texas and then back i mean one of the
top reasons he left is because the the
weather was oppressive
that uh that there was no public land
that there was no snowy mountains that
that the people in austin were rude but
uh you know
you went to austin austin's yeah the
liberal yeah
yeah they have a liberal mayor there who
goes to uh
vacation in the caribbean islands while
telling everyone to stay home and not
travel because of covid
uh just like most democratic politicians
who don't follow the law but
i mean this guy sparked an interesting
discussion but i do believe
media organizations like the daily mail
went too far
they kind of doxed him they released
public information about his house where
he lived
his family photos and i'm like this is
too far this is i mean people are
enjoying
calling him the new karen and duncan on
him but but for me but it was his old
house
yeah he didn't live there anymore well i
i don't know it looks they're showing
how
his house in in los angeles uh sorry san
diego
and his house in uh texas that he had
yeah he doesn't live it
it's still a lot of personal information
that's not really needed there and a lot
and and a lot of people were ragging on
the guy and i'm like but he did the
right thing yeah he moved there
hated it and left exactly there you go
if you don't like it and
you you move that that's fine and we
shouldn't be criticizing him
he does smart spark an interesting
conversation which i think we all should
have
and uh that should be it you know you
know what i think ultimately the biggest
problem is
it's that conservatives who live in
conservative areas understand what city
life is like to a certain degree
and don't care for what people do in
cities but people live in cities have no
idea what rural life is like and want
everyone to live under the rules of a
city
like so so i talked about it before if
you live in manhattan uh
even even i think luke accidentally uh
came out in support of regular gun
regulation
when i said what happens if you live in
new york city and you got it you got a
556 and someone breaks into your cubicle
apartment
and you said maybe maybe don't allow
certain calibers
well maybe some individuals we had this
argument i'm like we should get a
shotgun
i don't know my my walls in my rv are
kind of thin there
well so the point is i'll ask you alex
uh in new york for instance
i understand the right to bear arms
especially to defend yourself if you
live in one of these cubicle
loft apartments where you got 30 people
surrounding your
your you know 10 by 10 cube that smells
like sour milk and someone breaks into
your apartment
a certain you know a certain bullet's
gonna go through walls and potentially
hit other people and that could create a
huge risk
yeah so all bullets are going to go
through walls like there is no bullet
small enough that it's going to stop and
drywall
even like a with a hollow point 22 yeah
it would go
it would go through but i mean like but
just assume
that it's going to because this is this
is sort of the danger you get into with
gun ownership of you're responsible for
wherever that bull that goes
period so if it goes through who you
shot into the 12 year old
in two apartments down well that you
know you may have shot the guy yes
but the consequence of that you know was
you've you've created an unacceptable
consequence of that you killed a 12 year
you shot a 12 year old
so i mean this is something that a gun
owner needs to be conscious of this is
something that you get
through exposure to firearms in general
is you develop this knowledge over time
man could you imagine living in new york
city and there being a gun shop in
times square where they're selling like
a 308 and you just buy it well
it's right it's also clarify you know
i'm not for the regulation
but but there is there is a particular
gun culture
that that needs to be talked about
because when we went out to the range we
met a lot of random individuals in the
middle of the woods
away from all the roads and they were
all courteous they all looked in your
eye they all talked
to you they all treated you with respect
there was no attitude there was no
you know crap thrown your way there is a
particular gun culture
that is that takes safety very seriously
that makes sure
that you don't point your muzzle at
people regardless of whether the gun is
loaded or not
yes but but luke it's not about gun
culture it's about regular people
yeah like think about how remember you
made that video about being on the
subway with all those people everywhere
yes so luke made this video a long time
ago about being on the subway with
millions of people just keep going you
got nothing else to lose
and they never talk to each other but
how how often like we see videos of
attacks they happen
but how often does the average person
walk through new york walking past all
these people and no one just randomly
starts beating your staff same way with
driving you never really
veer the car over and ram into someone
you know you know when i when i was 16
and like well actually i got my license
and i was 18. but when i was like first
starting to learn how to drive
i was shocked when i when i realized
that cars don't frequently bump into
each other
i was like how's that possible you got
to park cars got to bump into each other
it's like well sometimes when you're
parallel parking you might bump somebody
but for the most part millions upon
millions of cars
every day drive within inches of each
other and never touch
and i was like wow especially taxi
drivers they they they drive like
crazy yeah freaking i don't know think
about that
and then when i when we went to the
range and there were some other dudes
there setting up targets and they had a
bunch of guns too
i have no no fear or no concern about
them shooting me or anybody else because
i don't regularly get attacked by random
people especially when you're at a range
when people are going there for a
purpose
people who live in cities are paranoid
and terrified that someone's gonna
you know you know what it is maybe maybe
because there's too many nasty people
who work in these offices or who are on
twitter
and they know that they're they're bad
people and they're just worried about
someone coming to their office and you
know
going postal yeah desperation can breed
violence obviously and in cities
sometimes you have poverty and
hunger but trust is like such an
integral part of being human you know we
got to where we are as the socially
constructed
species by trusting each other thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you